- 13, 14, 15...
n'est pas seule à vouloir voter
par anticipation aujourd'huiujo.
- D'habitude, il n'y a pas
de file. Ça a été vraiment
- Ils sont nombreux à attendre
en file  bureaux
de vote.
- De ce côté-ci, mon grand.
profité pour faire son devoir
en.
Marie-Flore Bellemare, 99 ans,
de Saint-Étienne-des-Grès,
tient elle aussi à voter.
- Eh bien, s'il manquait juste
Pour gagner!
- Dans la région d
les électeurs ont parfois
attendus jusqu'à une heure
avant de voter.à, t'as quand mêt
le tour au complet,
on en a pour une heure et demi.
À l'intérieur, on s'assoit sur
des chaià avancer tranquillemen.
- Le vote par anticipation
Depuis la pandémie, ce vote a
bondi aux élections municipaless
et fédérales.
JULIE ST-ARNAUD DROLET,
- On voit que le vote par
anticipation est dplus
populaire d'élection en
élection. À savoir si
inciter les gens à se présenter
davantagpar
anticipation, je ne saurais pas
dire, on peut le penser.
le vote par anticipation
aux élections provinciales
a augmenté, malgré une légère
baisse aux dernières élections.
la flexibilité de la formule.
on d'horaire, en fait,
avec les enfants, le travail,
le lundi c'est un petit moin
- Ça va être fait, oui. Puisj'a.
- C'est comme se débarrasser
d'une corvée.
- Une corvée comme un devoir,
qu'Élections Québec tente
par tousle plus accessible poss.
Ici Marie-Josée Paquette-Comeau,
Radio-Canada, Mont